okay i'm rolling this video has been a
long time coming
and i decided it was finally time for me
to
talk about why i left buzzfeed
before i worked at buzzfeed i was just
a girl who had gone viral on instagram
with a series of videos called the girl
who had never been on a nice date
a large you got to get money he got
money get it all for
him and that you know paid the bills for
a while but eventually that money ran
out
uh partly because i spent it all on crab
leg dinners but also because that's what
money does
and i was like man i need to get a job i
need a job like i need a job and a
consistent stream of income
so i can stabilize myself and then i had
a friend
justin tan who many of you know he was
working at buzzfeed at the time he was
like you should come
and do this taste test video where
you're gonna taste doritos i was like
okay oh yeah all right i mean i need
some money how much y'all paying he's
like 200
i was like to eat doritos i'm coming
there interesting and new
um i wish you guys could taste anything
so bad i was like hey can i
how how does one work here i wound up
going to meet with the person in charge
at the time he was like you want to work
here and i said i don't know what to
tell you people
i need a job i'm broke and so they hired
me
i'm so excited it'll just be the two of
us tonight oh no zack's coming too
zach and justin and i it formed out of
nowhere it was like
we have a good thing going we got a good
give and take and give and take can i
get an amen
amen what was special about zach is him
and i had the same sense of humor like
the same reference points
and then we both started making fun of
justin for being bad at technology hey
does anyone have an iphone 4 charger i
mean
i did back in 2010 it felt like we were
able to make things based off of what we
found funny
very easily together this is really
weird but okay
i just don't want to attend the party is
this something i did
oh my god justin no why are you kidding
me you're dear i just
would rather not and will not be
attending your party this girl
ashley perez who was the complete
opposite of me in every way she was
optimistic
bubbly and peppy she was
insistent on bringing me into this world
violet that was happening it was a
channel on buzzfeed and it was her sarah
and ella
and they had these characters and to me
it looked like they were making their
own little universe if she went anywhere
out of character she would have left a
note right you're always supposed to
leave a note she knows that
we watched 127 hours together you're
right she's fine
i was like all right i'm getting here
but i'm gonna do it my way it was fun
especially for me
to to kind of be like the like black
girl representation in that world they
were building i'm afraid of the
government
no one's policing them they can get away
with whatever they want and never give
me the talk
and you're also afraid of love oh man
okay the story broke i had this idea of
making this show
about three friends in l.a who uh like
me
you know we're broke we have two pieces
of bread okay an almost empty jar of
peanut butter
it was a test to see if they would watch
a video about
three black kids trying to make it
we got a paper we shot the whole series
and then we were able to sell the series
to youtube red
hey so that that was a really
cool turning point for me mentally as
someone who
wanted to make sitcoms
i'm sorry i couldn't hear you because
i'm too busy making strides towards my
dream
what are you two doing oh man oh my god
go indeed
for adoption was a show that i made that
is predecessor to what i'm making now
for abc i think
style wise i was obsessed like many of
us
with shows like the office and parks and
recreation mockumentary style shows
i wanted to try my hand at making a show
about a pet store i had gone to one to
adopt my cat
and i was like you people are
fascinating i want to make a show about
you
what's wrong that was the first time i
was like ooh
making something that's not based on me
it made me feel like i had the ability
to
to create different worlds which was
really
inspiring for me do you want some
they're for cats and people
some of my favorite memories were
getting to be creative in a way
that i don't always get to be now let me
get you some water my little sweet
[Music]
those moments when you just tell
somebody an idea and they're like yeah
let's do it we are tasting condoms
making you proud mom and then also
drinking on fridays
i miss that a lot we used to get really
drunk on friday nights
drinks for all my friends for me
it was time to leave when my ambitions
kind of became different than just
working
a nine to five requesting time off to
do things like write on a tv show and
that conflicted with with keeping a 9-5
job honestly
for me it felt like college and you have
to graduate from college and i think it
was really just time for me to graduate
in my world i had no negative experience
that made me want to leave i feel
fortunate to have had the experience i
feel fortunate to have
been able to support myself and not only
my myself but others
i was able to support a lot of other
young black creators that
otherwise may have never had a chance in
getting in this industry puente brunson
personally
has nothing but fond memories i looked
at as a really positive experience for
me
oh my god they want the t i think
that yes but not
because i left youtube has changed the
algorithm has changed the internet has
changed and
i think when i was there was like a
special moment in time and not because i
was there but because it was like
youtube and facebook and all that was in
such a
whoo everything was blowing up it was a
crazy
like phenomenon of like wild wild west
some internet creation
and then i think after a while i just
died down as
things do sometimes that's the cycle of
life friends
since i've left buzzfeed i wrote for a
tv show called laser wolf which was an
adult swim cartoon that was a voice on
the popular netflix show big mouth
and and we'll be returning for another
season of that show
and then i got casted on a show
called black lady sketch show which is
on hbo
and that was like a really cool dream
come true i sold a show that i'm
super excited about and super passionate
about to abc
called abbott elementary which will be
coming to abc
very soon you'll actually be able to
watch it like i sold it and it got made
and we're gonna make more of it and it's
gonna be on tv
and also i wrote a book that was a big
thing i did
this is the part i'm not good at if you
want to hear more about like
you know my life and stuff and even more
buzzfeed
juicy tidbits you can find it in my book
i have to do this
i'm obligated to this is what you have
to do when you're promoting a book i
hate doing this but i have to do it but
it is a good book and you should read it
if i do say so myself like
not to toot my own horn but i think i
did a good job with this one
quintet trip
hey whatever
you